ich habe eine Frage an Meike und zwar
interessiert mich das was für eine
Haarfarbe du Moment hast weil na ja ich
habe dieses Video gesehen und da hattest
orangene Haare war das eine
Perücke
oder ist die Welt
komisch weil es ist doch irgendwie
bisschen logisch al ist eine Perücke
sein muss oder na ja und die zweite
Frage ist würdest du die Haare mal das
Färben oder bleibst du bei Schwarz und
sagst so ich bin jetzt schwarz
eingestellt und es bleibt so oder
versuchst du blond oder so rot wie ich
das habe also so
naturrot braun oder was auch immer
und die letzte Frage ist was deine
Naturfarbe ist okay das ist bisschen
blöd dass ich jetzt nur Fragen zu Haare
und sowas gestellt habe es interessiert
mich total ich muss es einfach loswerden
und ich hoffe du kannst diese Fragen
beantworten okay also ich wünsche dir
noch viel Erfolg und den anderen
natürlich auch oh mein Gott ich wünsche
Euch so viel Erfolg und ich hoffe dass
ihr euch nicht nach 5 Monaten oder 3
Sekunden auflösen werdet weil ihr seid
schon irgendwie voll lustig irgendwie ja
und viel
[Gelächter]
Erfolg ja also du ich fange mal bei der
letzten Frage an von dir also meine
naturhafarbe ist dunkelblond die habe
ich aber schon seit Jahrzehnten nicht
mehr
gesehen
ja zu deiner anderen Frage was ich jetzt
momentan für eine
Haarfarbe schwarz schwarz schwarz wie
die Nacht ja und ja das im Video und und
das bei der livehow bei der dritten das
war sowas wie ein Experiment gewesen wie
du es da draußen ankommt bei den
Zuschauern bei meinen Fans und so und ja
ich habe dann natürlich dann auch die
Kommentare gelesen im Internet und
deshalb bin ich halt jetzt wieder
schwarz aber ich bin natürlich offen für
viele Experimente oder so aber jetzt
blond färben würde ich mich
niemals warum ne es ist einfach nicht
meine Farbe ich meine ich habe ja einen
Grund gehabt warum ich mich damals von
dunkelblond auf schwarz gefärbt habe und
ich möchte auch meine ähm schwarze Farbe
jetzt eigentlich behalten aber ich habe
schon viele andere Ideen me im Kopf mal
schauen ob ich die umsetzen
kann